The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK today, teaching
with blackboards and slides.
And also several questions
from the last time.
And, related to that, a handout,
which I've put
online, which is on how
to make a lesson plan.
So I'll do all that through
the questions.
So now just a quick bit about
lesson planning, because a
couple of you pointed out that
you'd have liked to know more
about lesson planning.
And reminded me that when I
taught the chemistry TA
workshops, I actually gave
everyone a handout on how to
plan a lesson.
So I've put that handout online,
and I'll just show you
what it looks like here.
So this is basically the sheet I
use for planning any kind of
lecture recitation.
At the top, you need some kind
of course, and date.
And then the objective.
So that's quite important.
You'll see the exact sheet.
And there's a PDF file, you
can just use it yourself.
There's a course objective for
that particular session.
And that relates to your overall
goals for the course.
So, for example, in this
problem, my objective might be
something like, to show
that easy cases--
in fact, this was
my objective--
I wanted to show that
easy cases--
extreme cases-- are useful not
just for checking formulas,
but also for generating
formulas.
OK, so I write that
on the top.
So I remind myself,
why am I here?
What am I doing?
Then there's a three-column
table.
Basically you just plan
items in your lecture.
The first column is minutes--
how long you expect each
thing to take.
And then the middle column, most
of the space is, what's
your goal in this local
part of the lecture?
And what are you going
to do for that?
So here's my overall
objective.
And my local goal may be,
just this example--
getting that one third.
And then here in the third
column is props.
So there's actually
a piece here, too.
So props are anything that
I need to bring.
So I just stick that
in the margin.
OK, bring the cones,
or the pyramids,
whatever they may be.
And so then, when you're filling
this piece in, about
what to bring, you just scan
down this last column, and
just write everything here.
OK, cones.
Homework three, solution set
two-- whatever it may be.
So now, at a glance, before you
go to your session, you
review these two things.
Make sure you have everything,
your know why you're here.
But then here, you're going
to follow your script.
Which is a loose script.
It's not exactly a word-for-word
script.
It's, maybe, a few equations.
Suppose there's a question.
What is this constant?
OK, so that's my overall,
what I'm going to do
for, say, ten minutes.
And then I break it into
sub-questions.
OK.
What is H and B?
How many pyramids do I need?
What's my goal shape?
So these are questions
that I ask students.
And for each one, I write
down the minutes.
Maybe in parentheses, put
the total up here.
So now, when I've done my two
or three pages-- and by the
way I find, just at the level of
detail I use, if I ever go
beyond three pages, I never
get to that material.
So it's just sort of for a
security blanket by the time
I'm beyond three pages.
It depends how detailed you
write these things, but I've
generally found that's
where I am.
And then, you estimate
the time.
And what you'll find is, the
first time you do stuff,
you'll massively underestimate
the time.
You'll be off by a
factor of two.
So, in other words, if you think
it takes five minutes,
it'll really take ten minutes.
And that's true even after you
take account of this rule.
Sort of.
OK, so then you put down all
your minutes on this page, and
the next page.
You add them up, and you make
sure that you're not over 50,
or whatever the amount is.
And then what you'll find is
what you thought was 50 really
is going to take you 130.
So the next time, when you
evaluate minutes, you'll have
a better idea.
And you'll find yourself
actually tuning your time
sense pretty well.
So now I've got my time sense
that I don't really need to
put the minutes down, because
I can just do it
by number of pages.
Three pages, too much.
And so you'll find your own
writing level, and detail
level, how many pages to use.
Now the other point is, where do
these questions come from?
OK, well this is a way you can
turn any regular lecture into
an interactive one.
So suppose you have a
long derivation that
you're going to do.
Or, for example, suppose the
first way I planned this, was
I wanted to show people that
this was 1/3 over here, this
is three here.
And the way I was going to do
it, was I was going to draw
six pyramids, show them in a
cube, and show that 6V, and do
all this showing.
Well, first draft, write it all
out like that, with times
and everything, without
questions.
Then, any time you come to
something interesting--
so here.
So before you have [? tel. ?]
So now you look at your sheet,
and you say, hmm, where did
something interesting happen?
Hopefully, there is at
least one point.
Because if there isn't, maybe
you shouldn't be giving the
lecture at all.
So now, let's just say, by
construction, you found some
interesting things.
OK, so that's interesting.
Oh, it's interesting that
it makes a cube--
it's not obvious.
So just think, where does
something require thought, and
that you're short-circuiting
the thought by telling.
So then, what I do is I have a
green pen, and I turn it into
a question.
So I'll circle it in green, and
write, "ask" next to it.
OK, or you can just rewrite
your sheet.
Telling something, then asking,
and then continuing.
OK so that's how you can turn
any regular lecture into an
interactive one.
And that's your sheet that
you walk into class with.
And what you'll find, is that
the first time you do it that
way, there will be a bunch more
spots you realize were
actually subtle.
Because, for example, at the end
of class session, when you
collect your feedback sheets,
people will have questions
about different parts.
You'll realize, oh, there was
actually something interesting
that happened that wasn't
obvious in one of these
telling points.
And you'll be able to turn that
into a question, as well.
The master sheet with all that
formatted for you is online,
on the course website.
And you're welcome to use that
in your own teaching, and
distribute it to everyone you
know Any questions about that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you run over
time, then you have to shift
some of the things to
the next lecture.
So how do you do that?
PROFESSOR: What happens when
you run over time.
The first time you teach the
course, you basically find out
there's just twice as much
material in the course as
there should be.
And you'll always be running
over time if you try to cover
every single thing.
So, the first time you
run out of time--
there's two approaches to it.
One is just to slow the entire
pace down, and cover half of
the amount of material.
So that's quite a reasonable
approach.
The other is to sort of keep
rhythm, but not cover every
single thing.
So my piano teacher, a while
ago, she said, when you're
sight-reading new piano music,
the most important thing is,
keep rhythm.
So don't just stop, and then
think for like ten seconds
about one measure, and
then continue in
this herk and jerk.
Just keep playing at speed, but
skip some of the notes,
and do whatever you have
to do to keep rhythm.
So you can try that
approach too.
And then, what you do is you
say, OK look I'm not going to
cover every single
thing in lecture.
A lot of stuff is in the book.
And that's good to do anyway.
So a mix of the two approaches
is one way to deal with
running over time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So each lecture you have
some objective.
And then, if you run over
time, then in the first
lecture, you only finish
half of it.
And then, the second one seems
to start from the middle of
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So that's one reason
it's worth writing
the objective first.
Because then you know what
the main goal is.
So one way to do it,
which I do like, is
to make sure that--
right away-- the objective
is reached.
So you do it as sort
of a layer cake.
So the first example--
maybe the first two examples--
just from those, if everybody
just doesn't do anything else
but the first two examples,
which you expect will only
take 15 minutes--
but it takes 40 minutes,
it's okay.
Because the first two examples
reach your objective.
Now they don't reach the
objective 100%, but they give
you 80% of the objective.
So you want to plan your lecture
structure like a layer
cake, or like JPEG.
People know how JPEG
compression works?
So JPEG, the way you do it, is
the low-frequency, quote,
"most important" terms,
come first.
And then the higher-frequency,
say, less important terms,
come later.
So sometimes you see things
rendered in your browser
step-by-step, and they just
sort of take focus.
And it gets better and better as
you wait longer and longer.
So you want to plan your
lecture a bit that way.
So that it's robust
to time shortage.
So that if, for example, there's
a fire alarm halfway
through your lecture, still
the main point got across.
Now it didn't get across in
all the detail, and the
beautiful glory of that you
wanted, but the main point
still got across.
So then, if you run out
of time, it's OK.
You say, look, there's two more
examples of this which we
didn't do, but they further
illustrate the main point.
See the notes.
And then you can keep
to your plan.
Assuming that your plan
is a reasonable one.
If your plan is that, I'm going
to do f equals ma today,
and I'm going to do rigid body
rotation tomorrow, that's
probably not a reasonable
plan.
And the fact that you ran out of
time on day one is probably
a good sign that you should
actually spend a little more
time on f equals ma.
Does that answer
your question?
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about [INAUDIBLE]?
A lot of people have told me
over the years that it's good
to write really big.
And I know you're constrained by
that the people have to be
able to see.
But, given that you're writing
large enough for them to see,
what's the advantage of writing
any bigger than that?
As opposed to having
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's
a good question.
Actually, why don't
we save that.
We'll talk about that today.
So the question was, how
big should you write?
Just enough so people
can see, or bigger?
So that you can keep the
full story there.
OK, so, any other questions
on the lecture planning?
And blackboard, and slides,
we'll come to
starting right now.
Teaching with slides
and blackboards.
What are the advantages, and
disadvantages of each.
I'll tell you my bottom line,
which is that my zero-th order
term, so this is
my objective--
if the lecture ends after the
next two minutes, at least
you'll have the zero-th
order term.
The zero-th order term is
that, if you can't help
yourself, use slides, but
otherwise, use blackboard.
For 90% of things, blackboard
is much better for teaching
than slides.
There are some cases where
slides are useful, and you can
make an argument for it.
There's some cases where maybe
the slide is as good as a
blackboard, few cases where it's
better than a blackboard.
But the default is, blackboards
are better than slides.
Now let me show you an example
of why that's true.
Suppose you're teaching the--
an example I've done with you
before, slightly, is the
Navier-Stokes equation.
Let me write it down,
to start with.
Actually, I'll put it on
a separate blackboard.
So there's our topic.
So we always know what our
topic is, because it's up
there, and it's just going
to live there for a bit.
And in fact, in some
classrooms--
you can't do it so easily
here, but my favorite
classroom is 4-265 because it
has pretty much this much
blackboards in the front, and it
has blackboards all around
the side, and on the back.
So I don't use the back ones so
much, but the side ones are
really, really useful.
Because you can, for example,
put the topic, like I've done
here, on the side blackboard,
and just let it stay there the
entire time.
You can put an outline
of the lecture.
OK, so let's say we
have a lecture on
Navier-Stokes equation.
We want to look at them,
try to understand them.
So here are the equation.
Well "are," "is," the plural
is a bit ambiguous.
This is actually three
equations, one because it's a
vector, vector, vector.
Already there, you see something
that's harder to do
with slides.
You'd have to work harder
to do that in slides.
You can just go back, and
annotate as you go.
And here, you can see the entire
topic while you're
looking at this.
So, for example, the student has
now got overwhelmed by all
the little symbols here--
the del squared, the partial
derivative, the v dot grad--
that part always scared me when
I was a physics student.
I knew what del dot v is,
but what's v dot del?
So you get scared by all that.
And then people forget,
they panic.
Because their short-term term
memory got filled with every
single, little, chunk here.
Their chunks are, remember,
very small.
And they forgot, what
are they doing?
Navier-Stokes equation
fluid mechanics.
OK.
And now, you can even improve
that first blackboard by
talking about, what does
this apply to?
Drag, turbulence, river
flow, airplanes.
So here, you can have a
reminder of why it's important.
So now that just stays up
there the whole time.
And people can re-center
themselves every time they get
confused of what they're
doing, just by that.
And then, you can continue.
You can say, OK, let me
try to explain the
meaning of these terms.
So let's do the terms
one at a time.
What's this?
So this term here is Dvdt.
We've seen things like that--
that's sort of like an
acceleration.
You can annotate the equation
right there.
That's also hard to
do on a slide.
I mean, you can do it, you can
work at it, but it's very
natural on a chalkboard.
Now, there's some things that
are common to chalkboards and
slides, which is the
use of color.
So now this, unfortunately,
is blue, which is
not the ideal color.
Unfortunately, I
don't have my--
orange is generally better,
but anyway I have blue.
Can you see the blue?
So marginally?
Maybe this orange, even though
it's not as big, will be
better than the blue.
OK, well this shows you an
example of color, and the
importance of choosing
the right color.
There used to be a green
one here, but
they're isn't green anymore.
Blue is not ideal, I
won't use the blue.
Let's try this.
Is that better?
OK.
So let me use this orange one,
and I'll try to write large,
even though it's not as bold.
OK, so the use of color.
That's important in both
slides and blackboard.
What's the use of color here?
Is it just because it's nice
to have a pretty picture?
No.
The reason for using the color
is that you get layering.
So again, remember the
students' dilemma.
Pretty much all students'
dilemma come from the
following problem, which
is that their
chunk size is one symbol.
You've been teaching the
Navier-Stokes equation for 20
years, your chunk size is
the entire equation.
Right?
So that's one chunk to you,
you just write it
down, like I just did.
But for the student, every
single, little
thing is one symbol.
So now, if you then write all
of this stuff in the same
color, as your rest of your
equation, it just
becomes more stuff.
They don't know how to
separate it into
two different objects.
But, if you write your labels in
a different color, it pops
out in a different layer.
They know that lives in a
different space, so you're
already helping them chunk.
So what is this?
This is also a change in v.
So it's sort of like an
acceleration.
Well, it's part of the
acceleration, actually.
So this is another
acceleration.
It's a change in v, but it's a
change in v because you've
moved to a new place.
So this is a change in v
because you waited--
you move to a new time.
This is a change in v because a
little piece of fluid moved
to new place, where the fluid
velocity is different.
So these two things together
are two different
contributions to the change in
v. So we'll actually call this
whole thing D of vdt, which is
actually its actual name.
So this is an acceleration.
These are the two pieces of it--
this is the acceleration.
What's on the other side?
Well, this guy, pressure--
p is pressure--
grading of pressure.
So that's the differences
in pressure.
So that's going to do some kind
of thing, like a force.
And row is density.
So you're taking a force--
I'll put it in quotes, because
it's not quite a force, it's
sort of force per area.
But now you divide by density,
and you get f over m.
So f over m.
So we have, here this guy--
acceleration is equal
to f over m.
Do you recognize that
equation before?
Yes, Newton's Second Law.
So this whole thing, so far
here, is just this is a
equals f over m.
So this is the pressure forces,
and this must be the--
and this is the viscous forces
divided by the mass.
So these are the two
contributors to the forces--
pressure forces, viscous
forces--
and those produce the
acceleration.
So the Navier-Stokes equation
comes out just as Newton's
Second Law all over again.
So now, this kind of drawing
is quite difficult
to do in the slide.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
would argue with you.
You could prepare a set of
slides with annotations, and
then you could do everything.
You could put all the
information [INAUDIBLE] in a
slide, or in multiple slides.
[INAUDIBLE] animation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you could put them on
multiple slides, and then flip
to it, one by one That's true.
So you can do it, which is
why I said you can do
it, but it's hard.
Because it is a bit of a pain,
and you can do it.
OK but then the problem is, you
want to now leave that on.
So now you want to have not only
this, but you also want
to have this, and leave it on
for the entire lecture.
Because this is the meaning
of the terms.
And now you're going to leave it
there, and talk about each
term, one by one.
Yes
AUDIENCE: But you could also
give them a handout, with all
the slides there, so
they would have
everything in front of them.
And if they ever want to go
back, they can look back on
the previous slide.
[INAUDIBLE] but I think so far
this is not a strong argument
against the slides.
Maybe the question's about
interactivity.
If somebody asks you
a question, what
about the third term?
If you don't have a slide
for that, then--
PROFESSOR: Right.
And this is the point
I'm coming to.
So there's that.
And I agree with you, you can
do this with slides, you can
give people a handout.
Though the problem with
the handout--
suppose you put all of this on
the handout for them, so that
now, when you erase this screen,
and that screen, you
go to another thing they
still have something to
refer back to you.
The problem is that you want
it all in one visual field.
And you don't have that when
it's on a handout.
So you have a problem
of split attention.
So now the student's attention
is switching between the
screen, and the handout--
screen and handout.
And when they look at the
screen, they're trying to
remember what they're
confused about.
And now they look
at the handout.
This is the analogy.
When I was in Prague, I would
look at a street sign, and I
would read the word, and look
at all the letters.
[INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
And I would look away.
Two seconds later, I could not
remember more than one letter
that I saw on the
street sign--
on the street name.
The reason is, because each of
the letters was random to me.
So, yes, someone who's Czech,
just says, oh yeah, that's
Main Street, of course.
No big deal.
What's there to remember?
It's Main Street, it's
in the Main Square.
Whereas me, as the foreigner,
has no clue.
And it's all new data to me.
So it's the same way
for the students.
This is all new to them.
So when they're looking
at something else,
you're talking about--
you're going to discuss,
what's the
dimensions of this term?
They look at this thing, and now
you have a big analysis of
the dimensions of this, you
want to check that all the
dimensions are right, and your
goal is eventually to work out
the dimensions of this--
viscosity, let's say.
They might be frightened
of the partial.
So they look at this, and they
say, oh, yeah, where does the
Dvdt come from?
And then they look back at their
handout, and they've
already forgotten pretty
much what this was.
Because they are
the foreigner.
They are the tourist
in this land.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I was just going say that
I would have said
something very similar.
The annotation part of it is to
[INAUDIBLE] slides at all,
because if I was making slides
for this lecture, I would've
done exactly what you did.
But it would all be nicely
spaced, and there would be no
handwriting issues.
So if anything, slides would
be better for that.
But I think that the argument
for slides is [INAUDIBLE]
having them linger on,
but also pacing.
Like, the fact that it doesn't
flip up so quickly, because
the [INAUDIBLE] that I've taken
where they use slides
and use [INAUDIBLE], it goes by
so quickly that you have no
chance to internalize.
The fact that you have to write
it out by hand forces
you to slow down, in a
way that is really
helpful for the listener.
And so that's something that's
really important [INAUDIBLE]
difference.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And that's a fundamentally
important point about pacing.
And this partly addresses
your question about how
big should you write.
So one of the reasons for
writing big, is that you're
writing slower.
And writing slower, generally
forces your pace to match the
pace that is absorbable
by the students.
So I'll come back to that point
in just one second.
So let me just finish the point
about the visual field.
The good thing about the
blackboard is, you could call
it cognitive offloading.
In one glance, everything
that the students
need, can be there.
So they don't really have
to remember much.
And the short-term memory
isn't overfull.
They're registers.
They're a low-register
machine.
Or rather, they have the same
number of registers as us, but
they don't store as much
information in their registers.
So their registers don't get
overfull, because everything's
right there.
Whereas there is a much bigger
danger of register overfilling
with slides.
Then, as you point out,
there's the issue of
interactivity.
So this is partly a performance
question.
Slides, not only are they
much more pre-prepared--
I mean, you can prepare your
blackboards, as well, but you
actually do have to re-perform
it each time.
Whereas a slide, as you say, you
just click to Return, or
Next, and there you are,
at the next slide.
So there's much less
performance in it.
And it seems much more
pre-scripted.
Now, what does that signal
to the students?
The pre-scripting.
It says to the students, look,
this is all one, tight thing.
It's sort of like a play on
a stage, that you're only
supposed to applaud at
particular times.
A modern-day play.
Back in Elizabethan times, in
Shakespeare's time, people
cheered, and screamed, and
cat-called, and it was a much
more lively thing
on the stage.
But now, everyone sits really
quiet, God help you if you
cough, you try to wait, and you
think about your coughing,
and then you don't think about
the play, and you try to
prevent your coughing.
So all that transfers a bit.
That same mentality comes when
you're using slides.
People think, oh my God, this is
a pre-scripted thing-- how
dare I intervene, and
break into that.
So if your goal is to encourage
students to
question, it's harder to
do that with slides.
You still can do it.
You can, for example, put
questions on the slides-- and
you definitely should do that
you're going to use slides--
but the random, spontaneous
character of your session--
the good side of that,
is going to be
minimized by the slides.
So this one was just to continue
saying, OK, now we're
going to leave these two on,
and we're going to do the
dimensions of each term.
I have one, two, three,
four, let's say--
four terms I want
to talk about.
I'll do the dimensions of
two terms on this board,
dimensions of two terms on that
board, now I'll have all
the dimensions there.
And now I can start, for
example, doing dimensional
analysis on this side
of the room.
And we'll eventually get to the
Reynolds number, which is
vr over nu.
Once we know this guy's
dimensions.
And v, we know his dimensions,
r the size of
your sphere or something.
So this is dimensionless.
Now you've got the Reynolds
number, you've also got, say,
drag coefficient, which is
f over 1/2 [INAUDIBLE]
v squared times some area.
So this is also dimensionless.
So now, you have two
dimensionless things.
And then finally,
the finale is--
So now, let's say by the end of
the lecture, you get to the
point where you've plotted
the drag coefficient, a
dimensionless thing, versus
the Reynolds number, on a
log-log scale.
And then you can talk about
this, you can go back and you
say, OK, well what is this?
This is really interesting.
It looks like it was constant.
And then what happened?
Well, you can go back
and talk about that.
And as you talk about it, the
entire graph is visible to
everyone, as well as the source
of all the pieces of
the graph, which is all the--
why is everything
dimensionless?
Well, you have it on
these two boards.
And what are the terms
that you used?
Well, those are all on there.
So all of that is visible
in one glance.
So that's an example of
something that is hard to do
in the slides.
Now, it's not easy to
get it right on
the blackboard, either.
You do have to plan.
You have to plan by saying,
what am I going
to put on each board?
And how am I going to structure
the boards?
But you can do that on your
lesson plan, for example, on
the back of the lesson plan.
Say, OK, how many boards
do I have?
And what am I going to use?
And then, if you want to take
advantage of the fact that
everything is visible all the
time, you generally don't want
to use the up-and-down
nature of the board.
You just want to use two boards
on each of the regions.
If you push this up, and start
writing on this guy, you're
now OK, still.
But then, when you push this
up, and you write on here,
you've covered this guy up.
And yes, you've lost some
of that advantage.
Again, you can plan it out,
and do a trade off.
But that is harder to
do with slides.
Now, your question about how big
you should write so that
everyone can see, versus telling
the whole story.
I think it is important to try
to tell the whole story.
It doesn't have to be the entire
lecture sits on the set
of blackboards, but a coherent
chunk of the lecture should
sit on the blackboards.
You have two things
you could control.
One you can control is the
writing size, and the other is
what you write down.
So this is a similarity
between slides and
blackboards, which is
you don't want to
write everything down.
Because if you write everything
down, then you say,
well for example, did
I write every single
thing I said here?
No, because I want the main
ideas to come across.
Every little detail that I say,
that should be either in
the notes, or in some book.
But the main point should be on
the blackboard at a level
of detail that people
can absorb.
It's the same thing
with slides.
You don't want to put everything
on the slides.
So, you can still write big,
if you just cut down
how much you write.
And generally, that is more
suited to what students need.
Because, again, they are living
in the dirt of what is
this, and what is this.
And you want to try to
bring them up higher.
So you don't want to spend a
whole bunch of time on all
these little guys.
You want to try to bring them
up higher, and put some
high-level chunks onto the
little bits that they have.
So use a big chalk, write,
large, just don't write
everything.
And try to fit a coherent
piece onto all the
blackboards.
It doesn't have to be
a whole lecture.
Although Feynman, at
Caltech, when he
gave the Feynman Lectures--
well, what later became the
Feynman Lectures-- he did
actually plan it so that he
would start at one corner, and
he would end all the way here.
And I find that's too hard to
do if you're also going to
make the lecture at
all interactive.
For example, if you're going to
have questions where you're
going to have the students give
answers, and you're going
to write down the answers.
Well, you're not necessarily
going to keep all the answers
for the rest of the class.
So the goal of corner-to-corner,
I think, is
a bit too strict.
But the general idea is sound.
Any questions about that before
we take a break, and
then go onto slides,
and slide design?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
comment that also, a lot of
students, if there are slides,
and they're available online,
they will just print them out,
and not come to lectures.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
A lot of students will just
print the lecture slides, and
then just think they can thumb
through them, and understand
the lecture.
So that's partly--
you could call it the
optimism of youth.
That they don't realize how
much they're actually not
seeing, because they didn't
actually come.
They think if they just follow
each slide, they've understood
everything.
But there's no way to put
everything in a slide.
If you packed a slide with
everything you said that was
worth remembering, or that was
actually part of the structure
of the argument, then it
would become not a
slide, but a book chapter.
And so, yeah.
I think there is a reasonable
argument that if there's a
book chapter--
maybe they don't want to come to
lecture if all you're doing
is reading the book chapter.
But slide, and lecture,
are so different.
It's sort of like, if you just
take a few photographs of the
blackboard, could you
replace the lecture?
No, but you're right, students
do think that.
So actually I don't like giving
them handouts of the
slides, if I do happen
to use slides.
Because it's really not a
substitute for a lecture.
It's an aid to the lecture, just
like the blackboard is an
aide to the lecture.
But what's important about the
lecture is, what are you
having them do in the lecture?
And that's the reason they
should come into lecture.
Because in lecture, they're
actually struggling with some
stuff, and you've structured
it so that they
struggle, and learn.
And somehow you have
to convince them
that that's the value.
And it's hard, because
of what you say.
Other comments or questions?
One second, in the back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
But at the same time, I've
probably taken at least half a
dozen classes where every single
word that the lecturer
spoke, was present
on the slide.
And then it felt kind of
worthless going, because you
show up, you pick up the slide
handouts, and you can read the
slides during the lecture.
You pay no attention to the
lecture, because he's not
saying anything that
isn't there.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's sort of the worst
of both worlds.
So now, what they've done, is
they've taken the constraints
of the slide format--
because there's only so many
words you can put on the
slide, and make it even
at all readable--
and often they don't make it
readable, and I'll show you an
example when we come back.
And so then they've torqued the
lecture to be basically
reading out the slide.
So now they messed up the
lecture, and the slide still
isn't really a good
substitute.
It's a huge problem.
I think the answer to that, is
that if you're going to use
slides, they're really an aide,
but the students really
need to learn how to read
a book, or your notes.
Or something that's actually
a coherent
presentation of the material.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when you write
something on the board to
respond to a comment, and it
[INAUDIBLE] some of your space
that you could otherwise use to
plan for the usual stuff.
So when do you erase
that comment?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
So how temporary should
stuff be?
One way to do it is to think
about the number of minutes
each thing deserves.
So that--
I like things like that to be
on the board the whole time,
if possible.
And now it may be that, halfway
through, I might
reclaim that board if I
don't have a choice.
But I'd like that to be there
for a while, at least, because
that's really the main reason
we're doing all this stuff.
And what are we doing.
So ideally, I'd put that on the
side blackboard, and just
leave it there forever.
Something like this, I would
like it to stay there the
whole time, so we remember.
So this, I would
mark as, "don't
erase," if at all possible.
So when I'm writing stuff
down, I would know, how
perishable is the material?
That's the word I'm
looking for.
So suppose I ask people
a question,
like the wood blocks.
OK, what's the frequency
going to be?
And we get a bunch of reasons.
I think the reasons are
quite perishable.
After we write them down, and
we talk about them, and then
we reconcile everything, I'm
perfectly happy to erase all
the reasons, and just
have the reconciled
picture on the board.
But while I'm reconciling,
I want them all visible.
So then, what I would do, is I
would try to have all those
reasons go, say, here.
I might cover that
up temporarily.
What I would do, is I would
write the reasons here, and
then do the reconciliation
here.
And then--
so let's call this
Reconciliation--
so this is actually the picture
that I would use for
the wood blocks,
which is this.
And I would draw a bunch of
arrows, and stuff, dot, dot,
dots, and spring [? bogs ?]
OK.
And now, I need to reclaim this
board with perishable
material on it.
So now I reclaim the board.
So this had reasons before.
Lots of reasons.
OK, and then, reclaim this.
And I still have that
reconciliation up there, and I
have this board back.
AUDIENCE: So you think it is
a good idea to separate the
perishable things on one board,
and then the more
permanent things on
the other board?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I think it is a good idea.
That's a good point.
I hadn't thought of it that way,
but that is a good idea.
Because that way you can reclaim
the entire board back,
and then replace it with
more permanent things.
Or, if something perishable
is going to go back
on it, put it here.
And then, when it's done, to
erase it, until a permanent
thing goes on there.
And then you move onto
the next board.
So it does require some
board planning.
But what you find, basically,
is the first time you teach
the course, you wish you'd
planned it more
in the first lecture.
But then you start to be more
automatic about it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a comment
on the performance
aspect of the board.
So when you were writing these
equations, and then as you
went back in the vector symbols,
and also when you're
circling things, because if
you're doing it right, the
students are engaged.
Their focus is [INAUDIBLE]
chalk.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good point.
AUDIENCE: It's as much of an
interactive activity as they
can with you writing
on the board.
Whereas with a slide, certainly
[INAUDIBLE] a
physical pointer, you might
circle something, but then
there's nothing there.
A laser pointer's even worse,
because you're not actually
touching anything.
Even if you have an animation
drawing, you're still
separate from it.
So I think that's a big
advantage of the board.
If their attention is at your
chalk tip, then that's some
degree of engagement
with that action.
PROFESSOR: Yeah that's
a really good point.
So the point is that when I'm,
for example, circling this, it
directs people's attention, and
then there's a permanent
trace left.
So you can, kind of,
do it on a slide.
If you knew you were going to do
that ahead of time, you can
make an animation that
goes, circle.
So you can do that,
but it's hard.
So one of the cures for that is
this tablet, a kind of PC.
So you can actually write
on the tablet as you go.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But even so, the thing is that
you're still over there
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I think
that's true.
That, actually, we are
together, doing
this, on the object.
AUDIENCE: Yeah that's exactly
what I was not saying very
well earlier, was you can do all
this, what you're saying,
on a slide, just as well.
When I do [INAUDIBLE]
presentations, I do actually
animate the circle.
I find that that's the
most intuitive way
for me to do something.
But it's not the same as
actually drawing it yourself.
It's not the same level
of activity.
And obviously you kind of have
to use slides for [INAUDIBLE],
but in a classroom you
don't have to.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so that's what we'll talk
about when we come back-- the
difference being technical
presentation, and teaching.
And then we'll actually look at
an example of slides, and
we'll critique them, and I'll
show you how to redraw them.
OK so break for 10 minutes.
We'll start at 10:18 sharp,
by that clock.
So you can set your clocks
accordingly.
And I will erase all this, and
put up a slide that we're
going to critique.
And then we'll talk
about technical
presentations versus teaching.
Because there's a lot of
misconceptions that come from
technical presentations.
And therefore, people
think we should
use slides for teaching.
OK, so see in 10 minutes, or
if people have questions
during the break.
OK, so our next task is to
figure out, if you are going
to use slides, what
should you do.
And related to that point is,
when are slides appropriate.
People have the idea the slides
are always appropriate
for teaching, because they
see them used all
the time for seminars.
So if you go, and give a talk
at a conference, you go to a
conference, most--
almost all the talks--
or at the department seminars,
basically people now come with
some form of slides.
When I was an undergraduate, it
was sort of transitional--
people came with overhead
projector foils.
And it was sort of shifting,
from seminars used to be
blackboard seminars, and then
they shifted to overhead
projectors, at least
in physics.
And now it's pretty much slides
all the way through.
But there's a fundamental
difference between seminar
presentation, and teaching.
And seminar presentation--
basically you're talking
to people
who are sort of experts.
They may not be experts in that
particular area you've
understood.
Probably not, otherwise they
would have invited one of them
to talk, instead of you.
So now, you're the expert
locally, on that local area.
But in the broader area, you're
talking to basically
people who are already
interested in, and are
professionals in the field.
And maybe some apprentices in
the field, who are going to
soon be professionals, like
graduate students.
So your goal is not to slowly,
necessarily, uncover one or
two ideas, especially if it's
a 10-minute conference
presentation.
Your goal is something like,
here are the core, main
ideas-- one or two points-- and
here's something to show
you that really interesting
stuff is going on.
And you should pay more
attention to me is part of the
goal of the seminar.
Now that's very different
in teaching.
In teaching, your goal really is
to kindle some new thoughts
in the student.
And who are very different
from a seminar audience.
They are not professionals.
Maybe they would like to
eventually be, but part of
your job is to kindle that
interest so they would like to
become professionals.
So you have a very, very
different audience, and
generally much different
time constraint.
In a seminar, maybe it's 10
minutes, maybe 15 minutes.
Rarely, once you start getting
well known, maybe you get
invited to give a 50-minute
seminar.
But, teaching, you generally
will have 50 minutes.
So your time is different, your
audience is different.
So just because slides are used
so much for seminars,
does not mean they should be
used so much for teaching.
You should really use them when
you don't really have a
choice, and when it seems like
it's the optimal thing to do.
So for example, art
history class.
Now, an art history class, it
would be fantastic to go to
Sienna, and look at all the
tapestries, and take the whole
class with you.
Now that's just too expensive.
So, instead, you show slides.
That's exactly why they're
called slides-- they
originally were 35 millimeter
slides.
35 millimeter?
Yeah, 35 millimeter slides.
So for something like that,
yes, slides are ideal.
And drawing the tapestries of
Sienna on the blackboard is
not even close to showing
the actual pictures.
So, in that case, 100%
go with slides.
Other cases generally go towards
blackboards, but there
are cases where, for example,
there are no blackboards in
the room, and you have
to teach with slides.
There's no whiteboard, either.
Whiteboards are not as good as
blackboards, but they're a
reasonable substitute.
But there's neither, and
it's just slides.
Or, yes--
AUDIENCE: Why aren't whiteboards
as good as
blackboards?
PROFESSOR: I find the markers
always dry out, whereas chalk
always works.
So blackboard markers never
quite work as well.
And the other problem, just
me personally, is that I'm
sensitive to the chemicals
in them.
So I eventually just get
a bit dizzy using them.
So I don't like him
for that reason.
And there's quite
a few people.
I'm sort of the canary, so I'm
more sensitive, maybe, than
many people, because I have
lots of allergies.
But I think lots of people are
bit sensitive to them.
But, generally, I find
the markers just
don't work as well.
And, also, there's very rare
room has lots of whiteboards.
Whereas many, many, classrooms
have this many blackboards.
When they replace them with
whiteboards, usually it'll be
one whiteboard.
So then you're back to many of
the disadvantages of slides,
which is that you can't get
a big field of view.
But now let's say you are
going to use slides.
How do we make good slides?
Well, one way to figure out what
constitutes good slides,
is to look at what constitutes
bad slides.
So this, here, is
a horrid slide.
So what we're going to do is,
I'm going to show you how to
re-write the slide.
But first, let's figure out what
are some of the problems
with this slide.
So, take a couple minutes
with your neighbors.
You can all see the slide.
What are the things that just
don't work about it?
And there's many.
It's a very competitive field.
And I'll write some stuff
down on here.
By the way, one thing is
that the JIT, that I
just actually shortened.
It actually was, "Just
in Time Learning".
I've just shortened it to
improve the typesetting,
assuming that the audience
knows what it means.
So the original slide didn't
have that problem.
So I see you found
lots of trouble.
Give me one thing
that's wrong.
Adrian.
AUDIENCE: There's no message.
PROFESSOR: What do you
mean by message?
AUDIENCE: What is the person
trying to tell you here.
You have to infer what the
person is trying to tell you
by analysing it yourself.
PROFESSOR: OK, no message.
So, the reader, the viewer,
the student--
this was actually used in a
class, never mind where, but
it's not here.
Yeah, what is the teacher
trying to communicate?
So Jean-Luc Doumont, if you
saw him during IAP--
he has a great way of talking
about what's a message, versus
what's information.
So the message--
so information, that's
what that slide has.
It has lots of information.
That's the "what." Message
is the "so what."
His native language
is not English.
I wish I could come up
with things like
that in other languages.
I think it's fantastic, because
there's lots of
"what." Well, 12% said Just
in Time Learning--
JIT Learning-- was a bad idea.
But your question is, so what?
And there's no answer
to that question.
So there's no message.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So a counterpoint
to that would be, this is
documentation, this
isn't propaganda.
Right?
You don't want to say, this is
what you should all think
about this data, instead of,
look at the data yourself, and
make your own conclusion.
Presenting the data in an
accessible manner is a
different issue.
But I don't know if I agree
with this, "so what" idea.
PROFESSOR: And some of that is
that, yeah, definitely in a
seminar, you lean much more
towards the "so what." And you
would put in the "so what,"
really first.
And in teaching, maybe you start
with the "what," and
then you lead to the "so what."
So, for example, the
wood blocks.
Here's the "what--" what do you
think is going to happen?
And I haven't said,
"so what," really.
And then we talk about a whole
bunch of ways of analyzing it,
and then we finally lead
up to the "so what.".
But at some point, you
do want a "so what."
So, yeah, without seeing the
entire lecture, it's hard to
know if they ever gave a "so
what." But I can tell you that
the succeeding slides just
went on to other topics.
So it wasn't that they
were using that
to develop the point--
what do you think about Just
in Time Learning, or how
should we analyze Just
in Time Learning.
They just moved on.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Going back to your art
history example as a good
use of slides, that doesn't have
anything in it that gives
you "so what." It gives the
presentation of information,
and then the discussion of
it is what gives that.
So I don't necessarily think
there's something inherently
wrong with giving information
on a slide, and having not
answered the discussion
in the slide.
PROFESSOR: It's not inherently
wrong, and
that's a good point.
So the art history one,
it's sort of a
different use of the slide.
So there, it's really like
you're bringing in a prop.
So the cones, these pyramids
themselves, didn't have a "so
what." They only got a "so
what" as we used them.
So it's the same way with
the art history slide.
It would get its "so what" in
how you discussed the slide.
But here, the slide
is really the
alternative to the lecture--
to the blackboard.
If you've gone to slide talks,
or slide teaching, which
aren't art history.
I think art history is really
a separate example.
It's, I'm telling you stuff,
I'm telling you stuff, I'm
just telling you in a way
that you don't really
know what I'm telling.
Like, I may be telling it to
you verbally, but the slide
doesn't match what
I'm telling you.
Sorry, you're next.
Go ahead first.
AUDIENCE: You may have already
said this, but is this slide
supposed to be for the students,
or is this for a
faculty meeting?
PROFESSOR: No, this was
for a course about--
what was the course about?
It was a computer science
course somewhere.
Maybe it was a discussion
of a--
no, it was a computer science
course, or a teaching course.
I forget exactly what course
it was, but it was from a
particular course.
So it's a slide used
in teaching.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That partially
answers what I
was going to say.
This material doesn't belong in
the lecture in any course,
unless it's a course
on teaching.
The surveys are filled out, so
they benefitted the lecturer
so that they know what
to do when planning
and running the course.
The students don't need to know
what the results are.
PROFESSOR: I think it wasn't for
the course itself, it was
for the students in a teaching
course, is what I
think it was for.
And either way, whether it's
for a seminar, or for a
teaching course, it has the
same problem, which is you
don't even know what
to think about it.
You just have a lot of data.
And there's no integration.
OK, so that's the no message--
the "what," versus "so what."
What else is wrong?
Yeah, Wendy?
AUDIENCE: The data is just
terribly organized.
[INAUDIBLE]
One thing is that there's
bullets under bullets.
By the time I get to
[INAUDIBLE], I'd rather skip,
I've forgotten [INAUDIBLE], I
don't remember what we were
talking about.
PROFESSOR: Right, so the
organization is ghastly.
AUDIENCE: And another good
comment, which is that the
numbers of the percentages are
not organized in any way.
They're not going from
highest to lowest,
or lowest to highest.
So you've seen, maybe 52, you're
like, I assume this is
going in descending
order, and then
things get flipped around.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the percentages are
kind of random.
It's sort of like the "what." To
organize it towards the "so
what," you would put
some theme in it.
But there isn't any, or
none that's obvious.
And the typesetting, yes, is
related to the organization.
The typesetting is a bit off.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So related to that,
[INAUDIBLE] the numbers and
the questions are given
completely equal footing,
because the numbers are
organized, [INAUDIBLE].
And so the numbers just follow
better to worse.
I'm sorry, the answers to the
questions are organized from
better to worse.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so then
it comes out.
OK.
AUDIENCE: And then it comes
out, but that's not
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the Likert
scale isn't obvious.
The Likert scale is the
better-to-worse scale of how
much you agree with
this statement.
Right.
So you're saying, also, the
answers have equal prominence
to the questions.
AUDIENCE: Equal prominence
to the percentages.
You have no clue what's
organizing the information.
PROFESSOR: Right OK.
So the emphasis is random.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
so she suggested [INAUDIBLE]
or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so
it's not visual.
A pie chart, or a histogram,
or something would help you
see much more.
So that's one of our principles,
right, that your
perceptual system is so much
smarter than your symbolic
processing system.
So you're actually slowing
everyone down, and making them
much dumber, by forcing them
to try to extract--
basically build a mental
picture which you
could build for them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'd say there's
too much.
PROFESSOR: Too much.
So what do you think
is too much?
AUDIENCE: All at once, you're
getting lots of text, and it's
all these different things.
Too much [? given ?].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
too many chunks.
It just overloads you.
You don't relate it to
the lack of messages.
If there are messages
in there, there
are too many messages.
You don't know what's important,
and what to pay
attention to.
Other problems?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Format switches
midstream.
PROFESSOR: Where?
AUDIENCE: At the bottom,
the last question.
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
You're right.
OK So the format.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's sort of related
to too much.
Right, I tried to put too much
on my slide, and I really
tried, really hard.
So the format changes at the
end, right, so they could fit
everything onto one slide.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Extraneous use of
bullets, colons, [INAUDIBLE].
Not helping.
PROFESSOR: So a random use
of colons and bullets.
And it's not clear how
those actually help.
Other problems.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that all bold?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think it is all bold.
So everything's equally
emphasized.
So all bold.
So again, it's presenting all
the information, right?
It's just you don't know what's
important-- what's the
"so what." Yep.
AUDIENCE: The numbers are very
far away from the text, so by
the time you get over there,
you don't know.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's sort of
like a table of contents.
And that's OK, for a
table of contents.
It's not ideal, but there are
ways of doing table of
contents that don't
have that problem.
For a table of contents
it's OK.
You don't need to sort of
get the entire table
at a glance, right?
You just want to know where
chapter five begins, and you
just scan across, and
you go there.
Whereas here, you can't
match the things.
You want to try to match it all
together, and you can't,
because the numbers are so
far away from the text.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
what PI means.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, that
was my fault, too.
I just tried to shift it.
Peer instruction.
Yeah, you're right, so there's
a lot of use of acronyms.
Yeah, so the JIT, and the PI
were my contributions to it.
So maybe I made it a
little bit worse.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how would you do
this on the blackboard,
instead, if you had a chance?
PROFESSOR: So this one,
actually, if I were going to
present this, I would either
draw the thing I'm about to
show you, or I would
use a slide for it.
Either way.
AUDIENCE: A slide with what?
PROFESSOR: I'll show you what
the redrawn slide is.
OK, so now let's redraw
the slide.
So I think the slide
that I redrew--
I'll show it to you--
basically answers most
of these objections,
though maybe not all.
I think most of them.
So what I'm going to show you
is what Michael Alley calls
the Assertion-Evidence
design for slides.
So Michael Alley, I'll
write his name down.
So Michael Alley, and his book
is called The Craft of
Scientific Presentation,
I think.
And this is to get around
many of these problems.
So the idea is, first of all,
so related to what Jean-luc
says, talking about messages
versus information, each slide
should have one message--
one assertion.
So that's the assertion
part of the slide.
And the body of the slide
is the evidence.
And it should ideally be visual
evidence, because of
all the reasons we talked about
for visual evidence.
So here is an example of that.
There.
Is this the entire slide?
No.
This is just one, basically,
third of it.
But you can redraw the rest of
the slide, with two more
slides, this way.
So this is one slide,
with one message--
most students like in-class
concept tests.
If that's the point you're
trying to make.
The problem is, it's
hard to redraw
slides with no messages.
Because you don't actually know
what the message was, so
you have to sort of infer it.
But hopefully the author could
actually infer it, and redraw
it themself.
So here you have to
play author, and
I guessed the message--
most students like in-class
concept tests.
The presentation is here,
with a pie chart.
And you notice all of the tags,
the "I like them", the
"please skip them," "I dislike
them." They're all right next
to their percentages.
And then, what's
color used for?
There, color is used to
emphasize the like.
So the green, and the light
green, are both
categories of like.
As asserted by the author.
I mean, you could say, well, no
"enjoy and learn from them"
is the only category that
matters, "like" isn't strong
enough, or really you shouldn't
lump them together.
You can have those debates.
But what the author--
the teacher-- is trying
to say, is that most
students like them.
And you can see it just at a
glance, because most of the
pie chart is colored in.
So this solves most
of the problems.
First of all, you don't have the
ghastly typesetting that
you have here.
The typesetting here is just
horrendous, this is sort of
typical PowerPoint
typesetting.
The alignment is nonexistent.
There's random alignment
lines everywhere.
If you look, for example, at
the way top, the yellow bar
doesn't align with
anything else.
The left edge of
it just doesn't
align with the bullets.
The open bullets are
just random.
It's just a big mess,
as you pointed out.
So here, just get
rid of all that.
And you can do this
with any program.
You can make your figure
however you want.
You can put one assertion
at the top.
So now assertion, another
synonym for that is "sentence
headlines." So you want
your title of your
slide to be a sentence.
If you're not writing a
sentence, you're probably
writing a topic.
You're just mentioning
something-- you're giving them
"what." To give "so what," you
really need a sentence.
So fit a sentence of one or
two lines there, and then,
give visual evidence.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: To sort of play
devil's advocate, I mean, I
agree [INAUDIBLE], but the
advantage of having all the
information on one slide is
you can see the different
things, and see the different
conclusions.
PROFESSOR: If you could
actually see them.
The problem is, you can't
actually see all the
conclusions.
I agree it's nice to see all
the conclusions at once.
So to do that, what I would
do is, I would make--
I think there are really
three messages here--
one for each of the questions.
So I made a slide for the first
one, which is about the
concept test.
You'd make another slide for
the Just in Time learning,
another one for, do lectures
cover too much material.
So now you have three.
And now, basically you want an
overall message of, overall
these instructional changes
were well liked.
Then you could have one summary
slide, which just
lists those three points.
And with maybe three small pie
charts, to remind people of
each pie chart, to fit
it all together.
But to try to pull it out of
that, the people won't
actually get the
three messages.
So you have to guide
them towards it.
Hopefully you can use this for
your seminars as well, not
just for your teaching.
This works for teaching,
as well seminars.
Now, how would you actually put
this into practice, in a
teaching example?
So that's what comes up next.
I'll show you a mathematical
example, which you could do on
the blackboard, or I sort of
optimized it so you could do
it on slides too.
And we can see how that goes.
OK, so here is just the
comparison, side by side, of
the two slides.
Just at a glance.
I don't actually mean for people
to be able to read the
words, just to see that one has
enough information that
you can get a point, but doesn't
overload you, and the
other is just a rat's nest.
OK, so then the mathematical
example--
actually, a statistical
mechanics example as well--
is the log of n factorial.
So we're going to approximate
the log of n
factorial using pictures.
Now why n factorial?
Well, what is n factorial?
5 factorial is 5 times 4 times
3 times 2 times 1.
Why do we care about it?
It's the most important function
in statistical
mechanics when you're
counting objects.
And it shows up in probability
theory all the time.
And statistical mechanics
has a lot of
particles, so the n is big.
So we'd like to approximate
how big n factorial is,
because it's so big we
take the logarithm.
OK, let's see if we can
approximate the logarithm
using pictures.
So log of n factorial is the
area of those rectangles.
You can see rectangle for log
2, log 3, log 4, log 5,
log 6, and log 7.
And log of n factorial is just
the sum of all of those.
Say, 3 factorial is 3 times 2
times 1, so log of 3 factorial
is log of 3, plus log
of 2, plus log of 1.
Log of 1 is 0, so all you
have left is those
rectangles to add up.
OK, so now let's add them
up, approximately.
So the area under the curve is
your first approximation.
So the curve is just log k.
So let's see what that is.
Well, OK, that's just the
integral of log k from 1 to n,
from the lower limit
to the upper limit.
So that we can just do
symbolically, you get n log n
minus n plus 1.
OK, now the error.
Where does the error
come from?
Well, it comes from
the protrusions
beyond the log n curve.
So there you have
the protrusions.
so we'd like to add up all
those protrusions.
Well, how are we going
to do that?
Each piece is almost
a triangle.
So let's just straighten out
each little piece of log k
curve, and make triangles.
And now, it turns out they're
much easier to add up if you
double them, and make every
triangle into a rectangle.
OK, so now I'm going to stop
here, and see if you can
figure out how to add up
all of those pieces.
What's the sum of all of
those shaded regions?
Take a minute and check
with your neighbor.
OK, when you see it,
raise your hand.
Find someone around who sees
it, if you haven't seen it,
and check with them.
Because it is fun to see.
I don't want to spoil
it unnecessarily.
Here's a little hint.
So what you do, is you hold your
hand at the right page,
and you whack all of the
rectangles, and they slide
across, and go psssssh, and
stack, and form the last one.
So that means the sum of all the
corrections, times 2, is
the last rectangle.
So log 7, or log n, is twice
your error, roughly.
So now you just combine the
integral, which is the piece
under the curve, with the
approximated protrusion, and
you get that for log
of n factorial.
So let's see.
So that is actually very close
to Stirling's formula.
Let's see how close it is.
Well where's the error?
Well, the error comes from when
we straightened out the
pieces of the log k curve, and
made triangles instead of the
funny-shaped region.
So the error is those shaded
guys, which is not very big.
And most of the error happens
low down, so if you just
corrected for that, pretty much
it would all go So here
is the total error.
Here's an example.
The picture method, so we get 7
factorial, gives you 8.594.
The exact answer for the logs
of 7 factorial, 8.525.
So it's an error only 0.07.
So all of this just
adds up to 0.07.
Which ends up being a 7% error
in seven factorial.
So the moral of the story is
that pictures can help you
approximate log of n factorial,
and here is your
approximation.
So one of the most important
functions
in statistical mechanics.
95% with pictures, and
one tiny integral.
OK, now.
That's an example or something
you could do if you wanted to
teach it using slides.
You could easily do that on the
blackboard, and normally I
teach it on the blackboard.
But I made this as an exercise
for myself to say, OK, well
suppose I have to teach it with
slides, what would I do?
And you notice here.
So when I first drafted it,
this slide was missing.
And I went from here
to there directly.
And then I thought,
oh, actually--
so this is about the
interactivity question--
oh, actually I'm depriving
people of a chance to think
about something,
and realize it.
On the board, it's really
easy to pause.
You just put the picture
up, and you wait.
And you say, OK, what
do you think?
And then you start
drawing stuff.
So I thought, OK, well you can
actually simulate that on
slides, too.
So I put the intervening slide
in there, so that people had a
chance to stop here, and think
about the result before we
continued on to the solution,
where it adds
up to the last guy.
So that's an example of
basically somewhat interactive
slide teaching of a
mathematical idea.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So why didn't you
animate a slide [INAUDIBLE]
with boxes to take advantage?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
Why didn't I?
Actually, because, A, I
didn't think of it,
but it's a good idea.
I should have probably
done it.
The problem is that I'm showing
it as a PDF file,
rather than through
any program.
So PDF animations--
I don't know if PDF has
animations in it.
It probably doesn't.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's true,
it's sort of against the
purpose of PDF, which
is a stable format.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I actually thought
this entire presentation was
really clear, and would be just
as good as if you did it
on a blackboard.
Because it was interactive,
slow, had pacing, the suspense
of having us ask
the questions.
So I think one of the major
reasons why I would be opposed
[? to teaching ?] in this way,
is just because it takes you
more time to create the slide.
From my own experience, it
takes a long time to make
really good slides, just
fiddling around with
[INAUDIBLE].
So I think if you could spend
all the energy we're spending
on slides instead
on [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: That's
a good point.
AUDIENCE: --or whatever,
I think that might be
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I think that is
a really good point.
And I hadn't thought of it until
you mentioned it, but
you're right.
It took me a long time to
make the slides right.
To do slides well, you have to
really think about the visual
presentation, make everything
visual, you're
making a lot of diagrams.
There's all kinds of
little tweaks.
Like, I made sure that all the
diagrams are exactly the same
size, so that when you flip from
slide to slide, you don't
get a shift.
So all those things, you don't
have to worry about on the
chalkboard.
And yes, I would advise people,
just as you do, to
spend that time thinking about
your teaching, and where
you're going to put the
interactivity in.
And do it on the blackboard.
So this is something where,
with a lot of effort, the
slide reaches to the level
of the blackboard.
But with colored chalk, and
lots of blackboard, the
blackboard is just as
good, and quicker.
And the blackboard has the
advantage that this could be
two blackboards in your class.
Say it's a class about visual
representations, and you have
two blackboards for
this thing.
The middle two blackboards for
yet another example, the end
two blackboards for yet
another example.
And you have all of
them at once.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Last time I taught a
class where I used all slides,
and when I put the amount of
time that, things like you put
into this, to make them all so
they perfectly line up, and
the animations were really
helpful and everything, just
creating the slides probably
took half the overall time
that I put into the class.
But I think the one advantage
was I was able to use
printouts of those handouts
as class notes.
Which I handed out
after the class.
They didn't have them
during class.
So that's the only advantage, is
you can reuse all of these
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And that's
exactly true.
So all these nice figures, we
did it for this class, and for
a seminar on making slides.
And then I used them verbatim
in my Street-Fighting
Mathematics textbook.
So basically, to make good
slides requires making
something pretty much
publication quality.
And then, you do have something
publication quality,
but maybe the first time you
teach it, that's not where you
want to be spending your time.
There was one other point that
was raised in an email
beforehand, which is, in
Jean-luc's paper, he mentioned
that he uses less popular
alternatives to the Microsoft
software for making slides.
So, yeah, I highly do not
recommend using Microsoft
software, because it's
not free software.
And it's, I think, unethical
to use non-free software.
Free software meaning freely
licensed, so you change the
source code, view the source
code, make your own versions,
do whatever you want.
And it's none of that.
Second, it's all proprietary
formats.
So you're encouraging
other people to
use proprietary formats.
No one has fully debugged, and
decoded, all the formats that
Microsoft uses.
So you should use open
formats at least.
Now, you could use Open Office,
but the problem is
Open Office, the whole model of
the way it does slides is
kind of yuck, because it's
just copied from
the Microsoft way.
So actually I prefer--
maybe it's because of my
computer science math
background--
what I prefer is to program
all the slides.
So let's see.
[? Log.tech. ?]
Where are the-- yeah.
OK.
So I actually write in
[? Tech, ?] or version of
[? Tech. ?]
And here is your title
of the slide.
And I can change the
formatting later.
AUDIENCE: Maybe that's what
took you so long.
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
Maybe.
But the thing is,
you can't make
publication-quality stuff otherwise.
So if you're going to actually
do a good slide, basically you
want to do that.
Otherwise, I don't think
people should bother.
And mathematical typesetting is
just ghastly unless you use
[? Tech ?].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
And I don't think you can
make it look as nice.
And I'm speaking here about Open
Office, and it's probably
a clone of rubbish
that it replaces.
The mathematical typesetting
is just not as good.
And so for technical
presentations,
it's just not as good.
So now, making the figures, I
have the same philosophy.
So the figures I actually
program as well.
Where is that fig [INAUDIBLE].
So here are the figures.
So this is a function that
draws logarithm graphs.
And then I tell it which parts
of the graph to put in.
So that's how I do the--
you draw all the lines, you
drew all the pieces.
And then here I call it with
different arguments, and I get
different figures.
So I'll put all the source code
up for you guys, so you
can see an alternative
way of doing it.
And some links, so you
can try it yourself.
And some templates.
But it's not for everyone.
Though it is a public format.
It produces PDF, which
is a public format.
So I actually highly recommend
it for those who have at all
some programming affinity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] programs
that ends up as PDF format.
PROFESSOR: That has
the advantage of
PDF, which is good.
So I do recommend presenting
things as PDF because you can
view it on anything.
It's just, you have the problem
of, do you have good
mathematical typesetting.
And that's hard to find,
except [? in Tech, ?]
basically.
That's the only thing
that does it right.
OK, so if you could just
take one minute,
fill out the sheets.
I'll answer the questions
next time.
I'll have office
hours as usual.
We'll meet outside that door.
And then we'll go to the cafe
area, and have a chat at the
tables, as long as people
have questions.
OK, so, the moral the story is
use the blackboard if you can.
Use the big visual field.
But if you're going to use
slides, Assertion-Evidence.
Sentence headline.
Visual evidence.
One message per slide.
Answers from lecture
nine, to questions
generated in lecture eight.
Audio quality for this video
is poor due to technical
difficulties.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
is I'd like to go through the
questions from before.
There's one question from the
time before, which is, could I
get the reference for the works
that said, there's a
difference between telling
people that they have
intrinsic abilities-- saying,
oh, you did that because you
are really smart, versus, oh you
did that because you tried
really hard.
And how those two ways of
talking to people-- and
children especially--
produced different interests,
and confidence
in trying new problems.
I mentioned that that work was
done a lot by a Professor at
Stanford, in the Psychology
Department.
Could I get a reference
for it?
The next update of the website
will have the reference, with
the reference is Carol Dweck,
D-W-E-C-K. And she's written a
ton of books, and papers.
But the one that [INAUDIBLE]
popular, [INAUDIBLE]
is called Mindset.
Which is a really, really
fascinating read.
So that will be on
the website.
OK.
First question was, you
mentioned many times, problems
that are PDF-- pass, D, or F,
where P is made a decent
effort, D is made an indecent
effort, and F is
didn't make an effort.
That's great, but then how do
you balance that with the fact
that exams become high-stakes,
hit-or-miss performances that
completely determine grades.
I don't use the exams
that way.
I give exams, they're balanced
with the problem sets.
The problem sets are PDF, and if
you do P on all the problem
sets, that contributes a large
part of your grade, towards
getting an A. So there's no
necessity to make the exams
all or nothing.
Problem sets still account
for quite a bit.
[INAUDIBLE]
It's just you're not forcing the
students to get every last
T, and dot every last I, which
often means going through
[INAUDIBLE] to try
to do all that.
Instead, you're saying, look,
I want you to try to learn
something big, important.
If you take responsibility,
then, you get a reward for
that, by saying, OK, that'll
help your grade, too.
About slide talks.
Were there any questions about
slides talks versus teaching,
versus blackboards.
So one of the papers says that
the best usage of slides is as
a completed form that's
understandable without the
talk that comes with it.
Is that for a research talk?
Yes, for a research seminar,
that's what you want.
You want two channels.
You want the auditory channel,
and the slide channel, or the
visual channel--
whatever's on the blackboard,
however you do it.
You want them to stand
independently.
So if people are deaf, and they
just see the slides, they
get something out of the talk.
And if they're blind, and they
just hear your speech, they
get something out of the talk.
That's, I would say, less
true for teaching.
The slides tend not to be so,
message, message, message.
You may develop a point, build
up a bit of suspense, and then
give a final message.
So there's more interaction that
happens from the lecture,
generally, when you're
teaching, than
in a research seminar.
So those are somewhat
different.
But generally, you do want
your slides, or your
blackboard work, to somehow
stand independently.
Although I've just violated that
principle right there.
This is meaningless unless
you've heard what I said.
But as I said, it's not
an absolute rule.
It's just that there's
tendencies that are different
between [INAUDIBLE] talks,
and teaching.
What do you do if you're
assigned to a classroom with a
bad blackboard situation.
In other words, not like this.
This is fantastic.
It would be even more ideal if
there was a slide [INAUDIBLE].
But what do you do if you go
to a classroom with, for
example, just one whiteboard,
or just one or two
blackboards?
Then you have to work harder.
Then you have to plan even more
carefully, how are you
going to use the blackboard.
And be more telegraphic.
Put coarser details
on the boards, not
every single detail.
Use the notes more.
So you optimize the constraints
that you have.
Should you only use the front
half of the room.
Suppose you're in a room which
has blackboards all around.
Should you only use the front
half of the room?
Yeah, I generally try to use
only the front half of the
room, because people can look at
that, and glance out of the
side of their eye at the side,
and then, the front as well.
The back forces people to turn
around, so they're much less
likely to use it.
So it's sort of like putting
something on the ceiling.
[INAUDIBLE] never see it.
So generally, yeah, I use the
front of the room, and
[INAUDIBLE] the side.
Should all slides have a "so
what" element, or is that only
for research talks?
Definitely for a research talk,
all the slides should
have a "so what," so people
know what the point is.
And ideally, for teaching,
you should have two.
Now, last time, I didn't mention
one of the fundamental
benefits of putting
a "so what," an
assertion, in every slide.
So that was the idea.
So the slide title is
the "so what.".
And then here is the evidence,
maybe a picture, or a graph.
Some kind of, ideally
visual, evidence.
So what's the advantage
of doing that?
It's not just for
the audience--
it's for you, as well.
What you do, after you make your
series of slides, with
your sentences, your "so what."
You extract just the
sentences, which is easy to do
if you're using a program
[? like Tech. ?]
You just [INAUDIBLE],
just the titles.
However you do it.
You make a list of sentences.
And then you see whether
the sentences flow.
With a sentence, you can tell,
very well, because whether
your presentation, your
teaching, your seminar is well
organized, if it herks and
jerks, if sentence one and
sentence two seem to have
nothing to do with each other,
there's no transition between
them, well, maybe you need a
sentence one and a half, a slide
that goes in between.
Or maybe sentence two belongs
down here, next to something
that relates better.
So you can see not just at the
level of the individual
slides, but at the level of
the entire presentation,
whether there's a thread
that goes through.
And if you remember, one of
the principles of good
teaching is having
a good story.
So this helps you make
When you're teaching a class
that has expectations for
teaching lots of material, how
do you reconcile your desire
to teach the important things
really well, and keep a
reasonable pace?
Some things aren't really
reconcilable.
Classes that, for example, say,
OK, we're going to go
through the 1,600-page textbook,
there's really not
much you can do to help that.
And students are just hosed.
But try to avoid that,
mitigate it.
Sometimes it seems like, just
out of habit, everyone does
that 1,600-page textbook.
But you could find out, what are
the actual requirements?
What do people need
for [INAUDIBLE]?
If may be a lot less.
It may be that a bunch of stuff
was just put in there
historically, and could
be taken out.
So you might have some freedom
to reduce that.
The other thing is you put more
stuff in the notes, and
you give the higher-level
ideas in the lecture.
Can I put my slides on
the course web page?
Yes, I'll do that, with the
reference, on the next update.
What about having slides that
scroll rather than flip?
This was a suggestion to avoid
the problem I mentioned of
signal overload, where you fill
up the short-term memory
with a slide, and then
you've forgotten
what's on the old slide.
And so, [INAUDIBLE]
too small to remember
the whole slide.
So what about having slides that
scroll, instead of flip.
And this may be a critique
of the PDF format, which
organizes things
in [? pages. ?]
I think it's actually not a
critique of the PDF format,
it's just a critique
of the PDF viewers.
So if you have a PDF viewer that
can scroll, which many
can, you could actually
use that.
The problem is that screens
are not big enough.
That's really the fundamental
issue.
So if this slide is taking up
the entire screen space, when
you scroll it, stuff goes off
these screens, and gets
replaced by new stuff.
So that problem is really
hard to work around.
What you really need is multiple
screens, and multiple
projectors.
Many questions asked, what do
you do if you're in a room
with a bad blackboard situation,
where you just have
one or two blackboards.
Well, almost every room has a
bad slide situation, because
you only have one
slide projector.
So you only use a small
part of the room.
So that's the really fundamental
problem.
And if you could get around
that, it wouldn't really
matter so much whether the
slides scrolled or flipped.
You'd put one over there,
one over there,
maybe one over there.
Of course now [INAUDIBLE].
My guess is that the t prepare
is probably proportional to n
cubed, or something like that.
Depending on the number of
slide projectors you
have to deal with.
Because you have to do all the
coupling of [INAUDIBLE] n
squared [INAUDIBLE].
You'd have to do all the
coupling between all the
slides, and it will probably
take you twelve hours for
every lecture that you
give, of one hour.
Which is kind of [INAUDIBLE].
Do I think the video camera for
OCW impacts the style of
my lectures, blackboards,
pacing, et cetera?
If anything, it probably
improves it.
Because I'm a little more
conscious that I write
clearly, and maybe it improves
my dress code a bit, because I
make sure to wear a tie.
But other than that, it doesn't
really affect, too
much, what I do.
And I usually forget that
it's even there.
It's much easier to write
equations [? in Tech, ?] and
then copy and paste them into a
presentation, than doing the
entire presentation
[? in Tech. ?]
Actually, I disagree.
This is a case of start-up
costs, versus running costs.
So there's many examples
of that, here at issue.
It's actually a general
principle worth knowing,
because you can analyze
lots of stuff.
Another example of this
principle is, suppose you see
a book that you really like,
that's available in print,
from publisher n, and there's
also a PDF file online.
Well, you could just print it
out and replace your printer.
Or, you could buy the thing
from the publisher.
Now, unless the publisher's a
total thief -- unfortunately,
many of them are, but many
of them aren't--
it's usually much better to
buy it at the bookstore,
because it's much cheaper, than
to print it on your laser
printer, get all the paper
trimmed to the right size, and
have it all bound.
So the running cost for you to
do one book-- you have no
start-up cost, you just do it.
There's no fixed amount you
have to pay, no matter how
many books you do.
But there's a running cost,
and your running cost is
pretty high.
Whereas the publisher, they
have a big start-up cost.
What they do, is they make all
these plates, they take them
to a PDF file, [INAUDIBLE],
they make all these metal
plates, and they ink
the metal plates,
stamp it onto the paper.
So they do all that.
That's a big start-up cost.
But their running cost
is much lower.
They're much more efficient
printing, per book.
But it requires all that
start-up cost.
So there's a contrast between
book publishers and you.
So it's the same thing,
actually, with doing
[? Tech, ?]
versus doing, say, regular
word processing.
With [? Tech, ?] there's
a lot of start-up cost.
No doubt about that.
It's not what most people
are used to, you end up
programming your documents.
And so, if you're only making
one document, if you only
write one letter in your life,
no question it's faster to
write the letter.
Your have lower running costs.
You don't have to worry about
the start-up costs if you
write it using a word
processing program--
Open Office, for example.
You just type, and you make it
look like you want, and just
spit it out.
But, if you have to write 50
letters that all have a
roughly similar format,
it's much
better to get the template.
You pay the start-up cost once,
learn [? Tech, ?] learn
some kind of program template.
And then, you just enter the
blanks into the template.
The text, dear who, the
address, and all that.
[INAUDIBLE]
formatting, that's all
dealt with once.
So you pay start-up costs,
in return for
lower running costs.
And that's basically true
of lectures, too.
Once you have all your templates
ready, it's much
faster to do everything
[? in Tech, ?] or in some kind
of programming, text-processing
system, rather
than in a word processor.
The problem is that, because
of the start-up costs,
[INAUDIBLE]
lecture the day before,
or two days before.
Because of the start-up costs,
you always say, well, I could
learn [? Tech, ?], and do this
properly, and it would save me
a lot of time later, but I don't
have the time right now.
And then you end up paying the
higher running cost to do it
some other way.
But each time, before each
lecture, it happens again,
over and over and over again And
you would have been better
off [INAUDIBLE] actually paying
the start-up cost.
So, to that end, I will put my
templates up, so other people
can use them.
So you don't have to pay so much
start-up cost, and you
can just take them, and use them
for your own [INAUDIBLE].
So I think that was the main
questions for this time.
Any questions that have been
created since then?